- [Narrator] This is
Wesley, a Patagonian mara.
He looks like a cross
between a deer and a rabbit,
but Wesley is actually a rodent.
Patagonian maras are only
found in parts of central
and south Argentina,
and even there they are
becoming harder to spot.
These cute little guys top
out at just under three feet,
and just over 30 pounds.
Their bodies are well adapted for running,
and they reach close to 45
miles per hour at full speed.
Grass makes up the majority
of this herbivore's diet.
They prefer living in areas
with lots of shrub cover
to protect themselves from predators.
However, a combination of
overgrazing and hunting
for their skin has caused a steady decline
in their population.
This is the Patagonian mara.